all right thank you so much so last  night was a very fun event over at Dell  Frisco's celebrating the new book  release of Corey Lewandowski and Dave  bossy and the book is called a titled  let Trump beat Trump the inside story of  his rise to the presidency it is a  fantastic book you're hooked by page  three no joke so it was really great and  the Steve Bantam was there as well to  support them and as you recall so former  campaign manager Corey and also deputy  campaign manager David bossy so it's a  really good read especially if you want  to learn a lot about the you know  Trump's historic rise from the candidate  that people thought we couldn't win to  the guy that got it done so very cool  here